Spanish convert to Islam and he joined
in because he doesn't believe like the
salafis do he's more of an AAR so he's
here so I forgot it's him he's a very
friendly guy so that me hey guys I
didn't know who you were man I thought
you were one of these shows but go ahead
buddy what's up talk to me no I mean uh
first and foremost thank you for having
me my pleasure buddy it's good so this
here yeah so um I don't know I have
questions uh if I can answer I don't
know if I can ask bro shoot I've been
going to so a friend of mine also
Hispanic he invited me to church wow I
know right I'm proud of him man I mean
hey he's Bolding up say come on bro come
let's go to church yeah and I told him
listen I respect you and I love
everybody so I come to your church if
you give a try and my mom oh so you're
one of those S snake oil salesmen if you
I like you man stuck and then I told him
would you do it he's like yeah we'll
give it a try I'm like just because you
said that I will go to church so I went
to church for one week I learned a lot
so I have questions yeah okay so did he
end up going to the mosque no okay I
like that guy already okay what's the
questions
about about the church buddy okay so I
have a question um so the the in the
Church they were talking about how Jesus
fulfilled the the prophecy when Jesus
was was talking about like how Jonah was
in the belly of the fish for three days
and three nights and he came out
alive so in order to fulfill the
prophecy right so he said the son of man
will be in the belly of the earth okay I
I I know this is Ahmed do but it's okay
you got it from the pastor so no no no
so the what about Jon no pastor talking
about it and then I I YouTube about it
oh yes you YouTube yes yes okay
yeah and you know I hear and then I want
to hear your version about it like what
do you what do you think about that what
do I think about it uh yeah okay what
about what's your question because so
for example they bring up go ahead so
for example right like Dr Zak
and you heard no just like Jonah was
alive he's alive right so Jesus has to
be alive to fulfill the prophet that's
what he says well he can say what he
wants is said the comparison is exactly
so I want to hear your perspective on
that no there's two problems with what
Nik is saying in repeating what he heard
from D it's not from n by the way it's
from d n it but number one he assumes
that Jonah was alive that's an
assumption but number two he assumes
that the comparison is the condition of
Jonah as opposed to the time that Jonah
was in
the belly of the will what do I mean
here let me show you because I thought I
quoted in the article I didn't but
that's okay Matthew 12 38:41 then some
of the scribes and Pharisees said to him
teacher we wish to see a sign from you
but he answered them and evil adulter
generation seeks after a sign and no
will be given to accept the sign of the
prophet Jonah for as Jonah was three
days this
is where Jesus is drawing the analogy
not his condition whether he was there
alive or dead but the period of
time as Jonah was three days and three
nights in the belly of the great fish so
will the son of he explains it will be
three days three nights and the Heart
sorry and the Heart of the earth so he's
not saying my condition will be like
Jonah's condition so whether he was
alive or dead therefore I'll have the
same condition no he's saying just like
Jonah was three days and three nights in
the belly of the fish I'll be in the
heart of the Earth for the same period
of
time that's the first response but then
I'll let you bring up because I know
what the other part of the objection is
so do you know the other part or you
going to bring it up no I don't know the
other part actually okay all right so
why should I bring it up the other part
will say well Jesus wasn't three days
and three nights and I don't even why I
brought up but I'm going to bring it up
anyway I have the article here Jesus
wasn't three days and three nights in
the Earth because if he died Friday and
he's buried Friday that's Friday and
then you have Saturday and then Sunday
so that's Friday evening all day
Saturday and Sunday morning that's not
three days three nights you see that's
the other objection that they bring up
the only problem with that is that's not
the meaning of three days and three
nights if you let the Bible explain what
it means to speak of two days or two
nights or one day and one night or three
days and three nights it doesn't mean
literally 72 hours it means any period
of time that will last up until the
third day how do I know it I'll show it
to you and I'll give you a Modern
English example just to help you
understand in English if I say how many
days a week do you work
six days but how many hours in a day is
there a day has how many hours
24 so you work six 24hour days my
daughter but you just said six days
dude okay I see I I work three days okay
Mama I'm Live come watch me you and
Zippy go to my YouTube channel I'm doing
good missing you my poor daughter she
misses me okay so so but you worked how
many days three days three days only
yeah 12 hours how many well no brothers
you said six days get
stuck but I thought days 24 hours so you
work six 24hour days no I work six 12
hour days so the point is even in
English you have what they call
idiomatic expressions idioms where a
person understands what you mean so I
say man I work five days the person
knows you don't mean 5 24hour days it
means that you work part of a day but
you can call it a day
likewise in the culture of Jesus not
your culture or mine when you say to
someone three days and three nights or
two days and two nights you're not
saying 72 hours or 48 hours you're
meaning a period lasting up until the
third day and how do we know here it is
Matthew
16:21 and that he must be killed and on
the third day be raised to light the
same gospel says that Jesus said he'd be
raised on a third day but if three days
and three nights were literally
then he which he should have said he'd
be raised up on the fourth
day uh right yeah I remember because I
read the Bible in Spanish yeah yeah I do
remember
that or here Matthew 1722 23 they will
kill him and on the third day he'll be
raised to life again on the third day he
be be raised to life so point being
three days and three nights for the
Jewish audience right I'll give you guys
the article does not mean literally 72
hours because if you meant 70 hours that
means you would say and he be raised on
the fourth
day it only means a period of time
lasting up until the thir
day so that's how it works so that does
not prove Jesus was alive in the grave
nor does it
prove that Jesus
did not remain in the grave three days
and three nights because it's not meant
to be 72 hours let alone the fact that
if you read Jonah very
carefully the impression given by Jonah
is that he actually died his soul
actually went into
shol into the prison and then his soul
was summoned to return to his body if
you read Jonah too carefully but that's
neither here nor there so that was the
first that was your first question any
other questions yes sir so
um man you're very knowledgeable that's
incredible well that's all brother
that's not me I don't thinkal educ
you're guided you're guided I tell you
well that's amazing a Muslim says I'm
guided
because I worship Jesus well that's
that's another thing that surprised me
right like for example when I was on the
live of uh I call him Avery God logic
right yeah so everybody was like can
every Muslim be this chill and I'm like
I don't know why non-muslim is like this
I don't know I don't know because we
have jerks in every group we have
Christians who are jerks and every group
but anyway yeah